popular valley restaurant has some extra
help but it's not what you think
servie is the newest staff member at
rachel's kitchen christian casadas joins
us live from the restaurant at the
district in henderson with quite the
buzz over this new staff member kristen
that's right brian and denise well let
me introduce you to servie now check
this out she is a robot that has been
helping here the folks at rachel's
kitchen for the last couple of weeks and
let me tell you she is amazing she's
helping out serving customers taking
their food and she even talks so as you
can imagine she has been a great asset
here to the team a big relief for this
business as they really try to keep up
with demand
meet survey a new server with state of
the art technology and quickly winning
customers over she's great she i guess
it's a she she comes over and she
delivers it and it's
people aren't really thrilled with
interacting very much with a ton of
people i think that solves that problem
this four foot tall talking robot with
sensors has been helping out the limited
staff at rachel's kitchen at the
district at green valley ranch for
several weeks a big relief when so many
are facing employee shortages because of
coveted fears it definitely hasn't hurt
i mean she's not here to replace anyone
she's really here just to help the team
members that are here
that you know we've been very busy which
has been great so she's just kind of an
extra hand that helps serve serve guests
we just put the food on top of here and
then we just
set the table it's going and we just
press go and
it goes restaurant chain owner debbie
ruxar sedate says the financial
investment is paying off after she was
searching for ways to grow her business
during the pandemic i've noticed it
takes the pressure off the people back
behind the counter so i i eat here like
three times a week it's been nice to see
that pressure off of them a three-tier
robotic aid helping this restaurant
staff serve great food while keeping up
with demand
[Music]
all right well back out here live so far
the staff is only having survey roma
indoors and get this she gets charged
overnight in case you guys were
wondering now she can be programmed to
be doing so much more but i'm told the
owner tells me that you can expect
uh survey to maybe pop up at other
rachel's kitchens locations around the
valley so stay tuned but honestly guys
she's a real treat for both customers
and employees christian casa is live
local now